The 18th
most common misconception
about Islam amongst the non-Muslim is
that if Islam
believes in one Allah last and final
messenger same, Quran same then why are
Muslims divided into sects?
And this is the common question.
Allah says in the Quran in surah Alimran
chapter number three verse number 103
Hold strongly to the rope of Allah and
be not divided. Which is the rope of
Allah? The rope of Allah is the glorious
Quran and say hadith. Allah says to the
believers, hold strongly to the rope of
Allah, the glorious Quran and the hadith
and be not divided. But commonly when we
ask a Muslim, what are you? Some say I'm
a hanafi. Some say I'm a shafi. Some say
I'm a maliki. Some say I'm a humbly.
Some say I'm ai. Some say I'm a bravely.
Some say I'm a salafi. Some say I'm a
What was a beloved prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam? What was he?
He was a Muslim.
If you read the Quran all the messengers
of Allah subhanaa tala Muslim. Allah
says in the Quran in surah Iran chapter
3 verse number 52 is Alisam was a
Muslim. Allah says in surah Imran 3
verse number 67, Abraham Alisam was not
a Jew a Christian. then you are a
Muslim.
Allah says in the Quran
that in surah anam chapter 6 verse
number 59
Allah says oh prophet if anyone who
makes sex in Islam do not
care Allah will take care of them in the
you have nothing to do with them Allah
says in suraham 6 verse 159 oh prophet
if anyone makes division or sex an
Indian of Islam. You have nothing to do
with him. Allah will take care of them.
That mean making sex in Islam is haram.
It is prohibited. THERE ARE VARIOUS
PLACES IN THE Quran and Allah says
in the Quran
in chapter number 41 verse number 33.
Who is better in speech than one who
invites to the way of thy lord? works
righteousness and says that I am a
Muslim.
The best person is one who calls people
to Allah, works righteousness and says,
"I'm a Muslim."
When prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam wrote letters to the non-Muslim
kings
to the nigabisia
to the king of Persia to king Hiraculus
the king of Egypt he dictated verses of
the Quran he dict and one such letter is
present in the koptaki museum he
dictated surah Imran 3:64 which says
people of the book
come to common terms as between us and
you. Which is the first term? Allah
that we worship none but Allah
that we associate no partner with him
that we erect not among ourselves lords
and patrons
other than Allah. If then they turn back
say bear witness
that we are Muslims bowing our will to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
This verse of the Quran says if
in the ending
say we give shada that we are Muslim.
So the prophet when dictated letters we
are Muslim. So the prophet was a Muslim.
All these great scholars, all these four
AMAs and the other scholars, Imam Abu
Hanifh, Imam Malik, Imam Shafi, Imam
Ahmed Hul, they were great scholars. May
Allah have mercy on them all.
They were great scholars. We should love
them. We should respect them.